the immense popularity of gore
Verbinski's the ring the American remake
of Japanese horror film of Ringo created
a tidal wave of interest in Japanese
horror in the United States and despite
mixed reviews of other remakes like 2004
The Grudge American horror fans will
find plenty to scream about in these
original underappreciated Japanese
horror movies whether it's body horror
or supernatural curses year after these
films are definitely horror classics
creepy director kiyoshi kurosawa is a
well-known author in Japan but his films
have gone mostly overlooked in the u.s.
2016 creepin was no different despite
receiving critical acclaim from the New
York Times what begins as a story about
the creepy neighbor next door evolves
into an epic funhouse of scares with one
of the most visible endings in recent
horror history audition before the cult
classic Ichi the Killer prolific
director Takashi Miike made the horror
movie audition you may have yet to cross
paths with this intense film mostly
because of the terrifying reputation
that precedes it 1999 to audition has
gone down in horror law as one of the
most disturbing horror films ever made
although it seems like a slow burn
mystery movie at first edition
terrifying conclusion is nothing short
of relentless dark water the poorly
received 2005 American remake of this
movie starring Jennifer Connelly is
probably the reason why the original
doesn't get the credit it deserves 2002
dark water was directed by hideo nakata
of Ringu fame and fans of that film will
recognize some familiar tropes most
notably the single mother and a child
fighting to break a curse before they
get totally wrecked by supernatural
force the dark water definitely isn't a
repeat of ringer it's got enough fresh
scares to stand well on a time passu
undoubtedly one of the strangest horror
films ever made
nobuhiko Obie Yoshi's how sue defies
categorization a group of friends
traveled to an answer
in mansion filled with an Alice in
Wonderland style cast of spirits
including a floating Monica Cheshire cat
and a piano that likes to eat people
released in 1977
alsoö is now considered a horror classic
not bad for a movie that was inspired by
OPI she's 11 year old daughter Battle
Royale The Hunger Games often draws
comparisons to battle royale and for
good reason there are plenty of
differences but both stories focus on a
dystopian world in which children
compete in televised fights to the death
battle royale is just way more violent
based on a 1999 Japanese novel of the
same name the film adaptation of battle
royale is one of the highest-grossing
films in Japan raking in nearly 1.9
million in its opening weekend despite
its success overseas Battle Royale
wasn't officially distributed in the US
but nearly 11 years because of the
controversy surrounding its violent
content G Goku it's hard to believe that
this classic Japanese horror film was
released in 1960 it feels as if it could
have been a yesterday when a student
flees the scene of a hit and run he's
not only pursued by his guilty
conscience but also by a demonic double
of himself - Goku translates to hell and
director nobuo nakagawa takes the viewer
literally to the fiery pits making G
Goku a horror masterpiece to the ages
Tetsuo the Iron Man
another J horror classic Tetsuo the Iron
Man feels custom-made for fans of the
weird body horror of David Cronenberg or
the fleshy ER David Lynch fictions black
Eraserhead
released in 1989 Tetsuo is about a man
who begins growing metal body parts
after he accidentally kills a freaky
half metal man nearly 13 years later
Tetsuo is still hard to watch making it
one of Horus most overlooked classics
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]